le prix du pétrole atteint un sommet en
trois ans à plus de 86 dollars
américains le baril à londres il ya
plusieurs facteurs qui contribuent à
cette hausse des prix notamment les
interruptions de production en libye au
nigeria en angola et en equateur la
vague de froid extrême dans l'ouest du
canada ralentit aussi la production les
pays de l'opep et leurs alliés prévoit
augmenter leur production en février
mais ce ne sera pas assez de toute
évidence pour compenser la hausse de la
demande et faire baisser les prix
analyse ce soir d'évolution des cours du
pétrole avec dominic lapointe économiste
principal à la banque laurentienne
bonsoir de mener que lapointe bonsoir
alors sommet en trois ans puis on va le
montrer assez rapidement dans le
graphique là malgré au micro le pétrole
touche des sommets comment vous
l'expliquez
mois en fait on retombe un peu à la
discussion qu'on avait au mois d'octobre
au mois de décembre en fait on a vu une
baisse assez importante du prix du brut
lorsque la variole où tout est à paris
on estimé que ça allait être là pouvait
faire diminuer la demande beaucoup en
2022 si elle ne va rien venait
contrecarrer leur reprise économique
mais shine on se rend compte que si paul
k pour l'année 2022 la demande estime
est encore très forte le point de vue de
l'offre vous l'avez mentionné l'opep
s'est maintenant je devenu le producteur
marginal de producteurs le mental
s'associer décision prévue la production
influence beaucoup le prix du brut est l
essence et l'organisation a ajouté
quatre cent mille barils par jour de
pétrole à chaque mois on se rend compte
depuis plusieurs mois c'est qu'on a
beaucoup de difficulté à rencontrer ces
coteaux là et ça fait en sorte que
l'offre qu'on s'attende n'est pas au
rendez vous et donc qu'on ne peut pas
baisser sa production de quoi 10
millions de baril par jour au début de
la pandémie on nage on n'a jamais repris
toute cette production
non à une certaine hausse au début de
l'année dernière puis on sait qu'on a eu
une entente avec les pays de l'opep et
ses alliés c'est à dire notamment la
russie pour augmenter graduellement la
production de baril par jour là quatre
cent mille pour que ce processus ne soit
complétée ça se retrouver la production
d'avant la pandémie avait pas au mois de
septembre 2001 de la stratégie en
arrière de ça c'est vraiment d'augmenter
la coutume en maintenant s'assurer que
le prix reste assez élevé parce que
c'était payant pour les pays producteurs
de pétrole de garder le prix élevé oui
j'en doute pas et donc de mettre de
garder un peu la laisse la sueur sur la
production il ya des économistes qui
pensent qu'on s'en vont peut-être en
surplus de production quelque part en
2022 y en a d'autres qui pensent que la
demande va qu'on a encore augmenté
vous nous avez apporté un graphique pour
les prévisions expliqué nous à quoi va
ressembler l'année 2022 selon vos
prévisions
en fait les prévisions sont retournés à
celle qu'on avait au mois d'octobre
alors que l'on voit sur le graphique
celle de l' agence énergétique
américaine jpac dès ce mois ci on
devrait être ont redit en équilibre sur
le marché du pétrole ou le toutes
lettres la demande qu'on avait perdu
street à la pandémie avait été retrouvé
et graduellement ne retrouver l'offre
donc pour l'année 2022 lorsqu'on parle
d'un marché du pétrole qui pourrait être
en équilibre à partir du premier
trimestre sa façon que le la dynamique
sur le prix devrait commencer à se
calmer nom qu'on pense qu'ils vont
continuer à y avoir des pressions à la
hausse sur les prix du baril pétrole
petit au cours des prochaines semaines
prochains mois si on veut mais
éventuellement
à s'emparer d'un choc important de
l'offre sont n'a pas de chocs importants
on devrait retrouver l'équilibré ce qui
permettrait au prix du baril de se
maintenir par contre si on parle des
années futures ce que changer ce qu'on a
réalisé dans le dernier mois c'est que
des dynamiques de transition énergétique
assez importantes et des dynamiques de
sous investissement chronique dans
l'énergie ferran ce que les prix de
l'énergie devraient rester plus élevé
compenser pour les années futures donc
lorsqu'on parle du p tit k autour de 90
dollars peut-être ce qui va pas retomber
près des prix de 50 euros le baril qu'on
avait dans les dernières années mais
est-ce qu'on servait à 100 dollars c'est
possible qu'on est à 100 dollars mais
lorsqu'on veut l'intention et n'assume
que le marché est en équilibre dans
l'est moi on pourrait monter encore plus
mais on va pas nécessairement touché le
sens de l'or pour toucher 100 alors ça
prendrait un choc quand même important
soit point de vue géopolitique ou au
point de vue d'événements
météorologiques par exemple pouvait
venir perturber la production est ce que
la hausse du prix du pétrole a un impact
important que j'imagine que oui pour
l'économie de l'alberta
oui ça aura un impact assez important
depuis 2014 en 2014 économique de
l'alberta a été très durement touchée
par la baisse des prix du pétrole dont
ce n'était jamais vraiment remis le taux
de chômage était resté élevé donc depuis
l'an dernier on a retrouvé des niveaux
records de production à peu près 3 8
millions de barils par jour de produits
si après ce qu'on avait il ya trois ans
par contre on est très très loin des
dynamiques des années 2010 2014 où on
avait presque 30 milliards
d'investissements dans le secteur
énergétique en alberta dans ces années
là pour 2020 si on était aux alentours
de 6 milliards donc même s'il vaut mieux
l'industrie est encore
loin de ce qu'elle était lorsque le prix
du baril étaient systématiquement hot
100 dollars et est ce que le prix de
l'essence lie et ce matin où je voyais à
montréal à peu près 1 dollars 56 57 ont
120 dollars soit 100 est ce que est ce
que la pression sur le prix de l'essence
s'en va en grandissant
ça va suivre la dynamique des prix du
baril sauver les choses en perspective
l'an dernier en janvier le prix du baril
est à peu près à 52 alors qu'on est
monté à 85 le prix de l'essence il ya un
an était petite a1 existent pour
démonter les 50 que vous avez brasse
unis donc en termes d'augmentation des
prix du baril qu'on prévoit ça
n'entraîne pas nécessairement le puits
d'un lieu de naissance aux alentours de
2 dollars par contre on peut se
rapprocher dans les unes et 80 si on
continue à voir cette pression le sooruz
l'offre qui vient pas au rang je crois
qu'on a fait rigoler nos amis de
vancouver parce qu'on avait les images à
1 dollars 74 2 litre d'essence donc le
dollar 60 on a déjà bien dépasser dans
l'ouest du pays dominic lapointe merci
beaucoup merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
[Musique]